[Musique]
madame monsieur bonsoir 4 millions de
francs ça n'est pas rien c'est la somme
que le fisc réclame après un
redressement à l'association du puy du
fou
fondée par philippe de villiers vous le
savez qui organise chaque année le
spectacle son et lumière aux herbiers en
vendée le président de l'association
jean marie de la s insurge il y voit là
une liaison avec les récentes
déclarations du député philippe de
villiers sur les affaires de fausses
factures sur ce sujet les responsables
de l'association donnait une conférence
de presse aujourd'hui présents pour fr3
marie-christine duper et max si près de
4 millions c'est la somme rondelette que
réclamait l'administration fiscale à
l'association du puy du fou
deux millions sept de redressement pour
l'exercice 87 88 et sans doute un
million pour celui de 86 contrôlé entre
le 18 mai et le 13 octobre 89 la
notification n'est parvenue aux épaisses
que le 12 de ce mois là surprise celle
d'aujourd'hui sa place à l'indignation
nous demande de payer un impôt sur les
bénéfices
l'administration se fonde sur une
interprétation juridique des textes et
je pense qu'elles utilisent des arts et
des arguments qui sont contestables et
nous allons les contester devant les
juridictions compétentes dans les
prochains jours le puy du fou en effet
30 jours pour manifester son désaccord
après ce sera de la compétence du
tribunal administratif de poitiers
toute la question est aujourd'hui de
savoir pourquoi l'administration a
changé d'avis et considère l'association
comme une entreprise de spectacle parce
qu'elle rémunère des palefreniers des
secrétaires et ne remplit pas ainsi les
conditions exonératoire parce que les
prix d'entrée sont ceux du marché
mais quelle est la référence la
cinéscénie n'est pas un son et lumières
traditionnelles c'est inacceptable
rétorque que les responsables c'est
purement et simplement un impôt sur le
bénévolat et sur la générosité puisque
en disant 6 millions ont été distribués
à des associations humanitaires sont
distinction de quoi freiner la bonne
volonté des quelques 2050 puyfolais je
suis assez serein car le pétrole en ont
vu d'autres et
et ne serait-ce qu des difficultés qui
se sont amassés au fil des années mais
je pense que demain nous avons
suffisamment de forces renverser la
vapeur et pour montrer aux yeux du
public
ce que nous avons fait jusqu'à
maintenant n'a encore une fois rien
d'irréprochable et que malgré
les comment les attaques dont nous
sommes l'objet aujourd'hui ne seront ne
feront que renforcer l'image de marque
du puy du fou en général
[Musique]